j'accueille titia titoff fait des
homards qui se ferait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or
pourquoi
bonsoir donc omar vous êtes dans nos
jours heureux de nakache et toledano
avec jean paul rouve et vous êtes un bon
acteur moi j'étais tout à fait sidéré et
vous avez raison de laisser tomber cette
[ __ ] de fret
on peut se dire et de faire vous même
des films sans lui enfin sans elle je
dirais vraiment bravo
je vois c'est le pompier
c'est ton pied tout le monde pour qu'on
peut le dire voilà
on ne touche pas on a tous un petit peu
et l'affairé est quand même bien encore
aujourd'hui et bouchaïb au frigo merci
tribaux martin matte rouge et toi
comment tu vas voir moi je vais bien
c'est sympa de venir dire au revoir des
dents ben c'est normal seulement des
choses
[Musique]
mais on va se retrouver sur canal
elle bureau à côté je pensais que pop
juste à côté on est en train de
superviser tu vas avoir un super truc et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu